上の方にちょっと落ちる感じ
なんか想像できるんだ
ちょっと滑稽な感じ
ドイツ勢がのつぶ足長いから
お腹の下まで
上だけでこうやってる感じで
トゥケさんでも
大丈夫?
何が?
えっと
ドンキー
ロバです
ロバだよ
ロバなんて
ロバ流行ってる
今流行ってる
ロバ
私たちはロバをやりたい
ロバをやりたい
ロバって人を乗せないって言うじゃない
でも
疲れがない
性格がある
ロバ
ロバやだ
ねえちょっと
馬の話してて
ロバになるのが
ちょっと寂しい感じ
せめて
ポニーぐらいに
ポニーさん
大馬か?
ミキは今
ロバすごく気味がある
アメリカ
こうやってるのは? 普通の馬はポニーと行っているんですよ。そのポニーは大きくならないというか…
もともと小さい馬なんですけど、そうなんだ。
最高が140cm以下はポニーということになってますね。
このぐらいかな。それ以上大きくならない。
ならないもの。 そういう馬。
サラブレットだと160cmくらいあるのもいるし、でかいと180cmとか。
西太が金メダルを取った馬は180cm超えてた。
それは背中までですから、背中までが180cmでその上に首がついてるんで、巨大な馬ですよね。
そうですね。乗ったら2m、3mくらい高さですよね。
結構怖いですね。その位置いて。
勝つためにはね、大きいもの。
そういうことなんですね。
深い障害を特に。
これ、おかわりをいかがでした?
今ね。
ありがとうございます。
私はこれを。
岩田さんもちょっと行こうか。
今日は天気持ちそうだ。
持ちそうだけど、昨日は何?
昨日すごかったんですよ。
昨日はね、あの。